so Herr utthoff sie haben sicher
dankenswerterweise entschieden den
Asterix einzutauschen gegen echte Literatur die
sich eher der palästinensischen Perspektive auf
diesen Konflikt widmet ja und sie haben Herr von
Wagner sich freundlicherweise in die Sichtweise
Israels eingelesen ja ohne mir diese Sichtweise
zu eigen zu machen das lag auch mir fern nur so
können wir den Menschen da draußen beweisen dass
es möglich ist eine ein friedvollen Diskurs zu
führen über dieses doch sehr polarisierende
Thema in der Tat ich beginne vielleicht mit
einer allgemeinen Beobachtung bei Konflikten
gilt ja die Sympathie häufig mal dem anderdork
und dieser undererdor so steht es hier sind bei
unserem Thema die Palästinenser sozusagen der
David gegen den Goliat Israel haben sie da gerade
die Palästinenser bezeichnet als Davids oh ja das
macht ja nichts sehen Sie in meiner Literatur
sieht sich quasi die israelische Seite eher als
der David gegen den Goliat der viel muslimischen
Staaten die Israel nicht anerkennen zwei konträre
Sichtweisen ja ich würde sagen da stimmen wir
doch schon mal überein schön ja schön schön
schön ja was ich interessant fand ist ja das
was hier steht was was steht denn da ach nur
da steht dass das Volk der Palästinenser
eins von Befreiungsorganisation wie der
PLO gezielt konstruiert worden ist um ein kleines
unterdrücktes Volk zu schaffen dann würde es nach
dieser Lesart die Palästinenser gar nicht geben
zugegeben innovativer Ansatz für die Lösung des
Nahostkonflikts ja ja dann würde ich doch sagen
dass jetzt steht hier allerdings dass in Palästina
immer schon Araber gelebt haben mhmhmhm das ist
interessant weil hier steht dass in dieser Region
ja dass in diesem Gebiet quasi bis zum ersten
Weltkrieg da da war das Osmanische Reich ne und
da gab es quasi keine Provinz Palästina sondern
da war das immer schon Zitat nichts anderes als
südsyrien von wem wenn ich fragen darf stammt
das Zitat ja Sie dürfen natürlich vom Verfasser
also der palästinensischen nationalkarter das
war wohl ein ein der wichtigsten Männer damals
in der Arabischen Liga wichtigster Mann in
der Arabischen Liga heute ist ja Cristiano
Ronaldo wo steht jetzt das das
hier sagen sie in ihren Büchern gibt es also
weder Palästinenser noch palästiner sagen wir
so sie als Linker nicht sind sie nicht seit
jeher für die Überwindung von Nationalstaaten
doch doch do nun ist es zur Überwindung eines
Nationalstaates extrem hilfreich wenn man erstmal
einen Nationalstaat hat so wie Israel das macht
Sinn ja ja ja da haben sie vollkommen recht ich f
ja auch noch seh spannend das hier zu lesen ja
was den ja hier steht dass Israel die einzige
Demokratie im ganzen arabischen Raum ist das habe
ich auch mehrfach gelesen hier wird dazu die Frage
gestellt kann ein Land das völkerrechtswidrig
Gebiete besetzt überhaupt demokratisch sein ach
sie sie spielen hier auf das Westjordanland
an näme ich an richtig das israel steht hier
besetzt hält weil es dieses Gebiet im sech Tage
Krieg von Jordanien erobert hat nachdem es von
Jordanien angegriffen wurde dass dieses Gebiet
vorher völkerrechtswidrig annektiert hatte steht
hier steht da auch dass netanahu angekündigt hat
das Westjordanland rechtswidrig zu annektieren
so wie Israel zuvor ja schon Ostjerusalem und die
Golanhöhen völkerrechtswidrig annektiert hat ich
frage mich ob das eine Demokratie wirklich gut zu
Gesicht steht nun hier steht dass man in Israel
demokratisch dagegen protestieren kann wovon
in letzter Zeit ja auch oft Gebrauch gemacht
worden ist nun steht hier aber wiederum dass
in den besetzten Gebieten den Palästinensern
demokratisch Teilhabe verweigert wird ja
das stimmt hier steht dazu auch auch dass
den Palästinensern die demokratische Teilhabe von
Palästinensern verweigert wird gab es doch weder
Wahlen in Gazastreifen unter der Hamas noch
im westjörderland unter der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde und das seit hier im Moment 17
Jahren ich würde sagen dann halten wir als schönes
Zwischenergebnis fest dass sich die israelische
Regierung und die palästinensischen Machthaber
in einem einig sind nämlich den Palästinensern
keine Stimme zu geben ja schön schön schön schön
schön nun steht hier noch was unschönes oh oh was
denn hier steht israel sei ein apartheitsstaat ach
ach das ja ja dazu ist ja ganz interessant zu
fahren Apartheit auf dem zusammen mit Südafrika
nicht definiert aber in Südafrika hat eine weiße
Minderheit eine schwarze Mehrheit systematisch
unterdrückt in Israel aber steht hier genießt die
arabische Minderheit nach dem Gesetz die gleichen
Bürgerrecht wie die jüdische Mehrheit mhm in
den besetzten Gebieten steht hier genießen
die Palästinenser folgende Bürgerrechte
Beschlagnahmungen von Land und Eigentum
Zwangsumsiedlungen drastische Einschränkungen der
Bewegung und rechtswidrige Tötungen ja ja ja aber
hier steht dass man so etwas nicht Apartheit
sondern eher Besatzungsregime nennen sollte
bei dem eine dominante Gruppe absichtlich eine
marginalisierte Gruppe systematisch unterdrückt
also wenn Sie so wollen interessant denn das
ist genau die Definition von apareit durch den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof steht hier ach
ja aber steht da auch dass man diesen Begriff der
apart hat auf die besetzten Gebiete anwenden
sollte nein Amnesty International wendet ihn
auf ganz Israel an vielleicht könnten wir es
so machen und eine strikte Trennung einführen
also zwischen der Kritik an den untragbaren
Zuständen in den besetzten Gebieten und der
untragbaren Kritik an Israel als jüdischenem
Staat insgesamt sie meinen eine Apartheit in
der apartheitsfrage ja schön schön schön schön
schön schön ja jetzt steht hier noch eine kleine
Sache mhm was für eine kleine Sache steht den
da hier hier steht israel sei ein Kolonialstaat
bei dem weiße jüdische Siedler ein indigenes
arabisches Volk verdrängt hätten ja ich nehme
an sie sprechen hier von der sogenannten nabaar
also der Vertreibung von über 700.000 palästiner
nenssern bei der Gründung des Staates Israel im
Jahre 47 48 das war eine ethnische Säuberung steht
hier wovon sie jetzt nicht sprechen sind die
über 900.000 Juden die aus arabischen Ländern
geflüchtet sind damals nach der Gründung
des Staates Israel im Jahre 47 48 steht
hier ich glaube
ja sehen Sie und hier 50% der Bevölkerung Israels
sind deshalb nicht weiß W sie stammen
aus Marokko Algerien Tunesien Libyen
Ägypten Syrien Irak jeemen Herr von
Wagner wer waren jetzt noch mal die
indigenen gute Frage die die die Juden
selbst waren ja quasi indigenigen denn
sie stammten ja aus aus aus dieser
Region das steht hier ach wo steht
das in der Bibel halten Sie es für
eine gute Idee realpolitisches Problem
lösen zu wollen mit einem alten Märchen
über einen fiktiven Gott hier steht den
gibts hier steht allerdings dass ab
den 20er Jahren massenhaft Juden nach
Palästina eingewandert sind ja das habe ich
auch gelesen ich habe aber auch gelesen dass
zum selben Zeitpunkt auch massenhaft Araber
eingewandert sind her von Wagner wenn da
dauernd massenhaft Menschen angesiedelt kamen
wessen Kolonie war es denn dann noch eine gute
Frage also eine Kolonie ist doch so eine
Art Zweigstelle des des heimatstaatus nicht
ja durchaus ja ja jetzt hatten die Juden
ja damals gar keinen Heimatstaat aber sie
haben Palästina zu ihrer Kolonie gemacht obwohl
sie ursprünglich daher stammten dann haben sie
ihre alte Heimat kolonisiert aber Palästina
war doch schon eine Kolonie ach von wem von
Großbritannien wollen wir uns darauf einigen
dass die brittenen Schuld sind sehr gerne
wobei haben wir da nicht vielleicht eine
Nation übersehen die ja an der Vernichtung
und Vertreibung der Juden einen nicht ganz
unwesentlichen Anteil hatten hier steht
Deutschland ja auch sind sie wenn die Juden
überall Verfolg gewen sind und dann dann dann
brauchten sie damals eben einen Heimatstaat in
Palästina so wie die Palästinenser aber doch
heute auch einen Staat brauchen interessanterweise
er hat hier damals die UN ja auch 47 beschlossen
neben dem jüdischen einen arabischen Staat
zu grüen ja aber hier steht der Vorschlag
war ungerecht wegen der gebietsverteilung und
die arabische Seite hat ih abgelehnt ja ja ja
aber hier steht die arabische Seite hat einen
Krieg angefangen ja ist das der Grund warum
sie bis heute keinen startaat haben also der
Grund ist glaube ich der Stapel da drüben ich
finde so wichtig ist die Frage für mich nein nein
nein nein aber ich finde wir haben auf jeden Fall
gezeigt dass man auch über dieses polarisierende
Thema einen friedvollen Dialog führen kann schön
schön [Musik] danke vor allem wenn man vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass Israel in einem
brutalen Krieg schon 17000 Palästinenser
getötet hat ein Krieg den ja wohl die Hamas
begonnen hat eine Organisation die bereits in
ihrer gründungskarte die Vernichtung Israels
aufschreibt apropos Vernichtung der israelische
Minister für Kulturerbe hielt Atombomben auf
Gaza für eine Option das können jetzt alle
Israelis für einen radikalen irläufer sie
haben einen zum Ministerpräsidenten gewählt
okay und die Hamas besteht nur aus radikalen
irläufer ja Netanyahu hat die Hamas aber doch
selbst benutzt um die Palästinenser zu spalten
ja ja aber die Hamas die die hat ja schon noch
einen Einfluss auf ihrre eigenen Massaker ne
Israel könnte diesen Krieg sofort beenden mit
einer Waffenruhe ah ja ja ja W ruft denn mal
die Hamas zur Waffenruhe aus die haben immer noch
138 Geiseln Israel wird immer noch beschossen die
Hamas muss weg aber doch nicht so ja aber
wie denn dann mit Satire sie können eine
Idee doch nicht wegbomben das hat bei
den Nazis aber schon gut funktioniert
wirklich wirklich ja dann fragen Sie
doch mal Herrn höcke was er davon hält
allm dass die Weihnachten immer so ruinieren
müssen weißt du was jetzt richtig gut wäre Wackler
was Wackler was her wir haben was vergessen was
denn na das Abo und die Glocke was dann dann
war das hier alles ganz umsonst ich fürchte
ja vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
ja auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
dass S jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr
klug